afrika und die kamera ist jetzt sogar so
aufgebaut wie früher beim iphone 4 mit
diesem denken hey was geht ab von
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich hab schon ein bisschen
vermisst ich glaube ich habe jetzt
wirklich was sie nicht eine woche oder
so pause gemacht war eigentlich gar
nicht so geplant nur ich muss jetzt
heute noch eine klausur schreiben die
ein bisschen schwieriger war da muss ich
ein bisschen für lernen und deswegen
habe ich mir jetzt einfach mal die woche
ein bisschen mehr darauf konzentriert
jetzt gehts aber wieder los ich habe
wirklich eine menge coole ideen die ich
alle noch im januar und februar umsetzen
möchte also die werden wirklich cool und
heute fangen wir auch direkt was
kuhlemann ich weiß ja wenn man das video
erinnern können vor ungefähr drei wochen
kam das wohl schon mal so ein fake
iphone fotos gezeigt hat natürlich muss
man sagen ich habe in letzter zeit sehr
oft sowie videos gemacht ich weiß ich
habe mir das video gesehen habe wo ich
über das ende von alex wir gesprochen
habe also das ist eine kleine
veränderung geben wird und dass ich
jetzt halt mehr versuche produktvideos
zu machen aber natürlich auch anderen
coolen shit und der kommt jetzt auch
schon übermorgen bin gespannt wie es
ankommt wir machen heute erstmal das
iphone iks ich habe mich nämlich
versucht zu beschwert hat nicht geklappt
weil das handy ging ja nicht was ding
ist ich könnte das jetzt zurückziehen
und reklamieren kostet aber ziemlich
viel an versandkosten von daher war es
mir egal ich wollte es allerdings nicht
so auf mir sitzen lassen und habe noch
eingekauft ein besseres was teurer war
hier ist das schöne paket wie man sehen
kann es ist ein handy und ich würde
sagen na schauen wir jetzt sofort mal
rein ich hoffe natürlich wirklich dass
es dieses mal einfach funktioniert und
keine schwierigkeiten gehabt so wie beim
letzten mal war das hat mich echt extrem
abgefahren bevor wir das machen wir mal
wir schauen uns das produkt einfach mal
kurz an
was hat er lieber alex dargestellt weil
das ganze ist jetzt auch schon wieder
ein bisschen was her
das ist das produkt es hat mich
unglaublich 104 euro gekostet also
man muss aber auch sagen es sieht 100
gleich aus wie das iphone xl original
zumindest hier auf diesen produktbildern
hier habe ich jetzt einmal das iphone xs
und so sieht das ganze aus und das hier
ist wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht
der fake vom iphone xs wobei ja auch
alle sehr ähnlich aussehen also sei von
xs gibt es jetzt wohl gar nicht mehr
keine ahnung 104 euro für ein fake handy
muss man erst mal schlucken
ich habe es einfach bestellt wir haben
hier 3,5 sterne bewertungen claudia
schreibt voll zufrieden alles super maße
schreibt besser als erwartet super handy
für den preis eines von reset von time
to time blablabla also ich bin diesmal
wirklich gespannt auf 14 eur
expressversand kam auch noch dazu wir
schauen uns noch mal kurz die
beschreibung an
natürlich haben wir ein android system
und kein ios aber das ist halt so zwei
gigabyte arbeitsspeicher 16 gb für fotos
ich erzähle ich hatte sie auch im
letzten video schon gesagt die werben
mit einer face die machen die hier auch
und ob das wirklich alles funktioniert
schauen das heute mal an ich bin
wirklich gespannt und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim zuschauen
das gerne doch nach oben dafür noch mehr
handy reviews ich habe die woche noch
ein cooles handy zugeschickt bekommen
das wohl unzerstörbar ist das schauen
wir uns mal an wir machen jetzt erst mal
dieses paket auch so leute also wir
machen das paket mal auf
geil ok also wenn man das jetzt direkt
mal mit dem was ich da vorbestellt hat
vergleicht wir haben hier direkt
zumindest eine verpackung mit dem iphone
soll doch das ixs sein ich weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall der verpackung die eine
iphone verpackung ähnelt bis auf das
hier und jetzt fühlt sich nicht ganz so
hochwertig an
trotzdem ganz cool da bin ich jetzt
schon mal positiv beeindruckt von dem
hier steht drauf rodney bay
jetzt habe ich es gesehen die dürfen
kein apple logo verwenden darauf bin ich
mir sicher
weil es sonst ärger gibt also das handy
nennt sich ok
warum auch nicht so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was mich erwartet ja auch das
hier sieht eins zu eins gleich aus wie
beim iphone macht man jetzt auf ob wir
haben sogar wir haben sogar eine rolle
dabei dass jan also das beeindruckt mich
jetzt wirklich wehren wenn man eine
hülle eine schutzhülle und wir haben ja
auch noch so panzerglas einfach für den
display
da können sich andere hersteller man die
scheibe von abschneiden würde ich sagen
ist nicht schlecht ja aber wenn wir
jetzt als nächstes zum handy dabei kann
ich euch direkt mal von meiner idee
erzählen für weitere videos und so habe
ich mir gedacht ich bekomme so oft
produkte zugeschickt warum verkauft sie
die nicht einfach mal also dass ich dann
wieder das zu machen und euch dann
praktisch mitnehme wie ich dafür
käufersuche und mal schauen wie viel
geld ich dann für das produkt bekomme
zum beispiel dann über ebay
kleinanzeigen also wie viel zahlen leute
für so einen fake iphone und gibt es
überhaupt jemand ja das haben will egal
das handy sieht folgendermaßen aus
ja dann schleppt ich ziehe mal direkt
die schutzfolie ab und das nicht
wirklich nicht aus was mir aber direkt
auffällt der bildschirm ist nicht
komplett gefüllt werden wir unseren
trotzdem so einen leichten aber das geht
nur bis hier normalerweise bei den
iphone apps die sind ja komplett bis
unten durchgezogen also der bildschirm
aber gut hier steht jetzt hotrec drauf
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht mich hat
man gesehen dass jemand dann diese folie
abgezogen hat hier runter sollte das
apple-logo seien keine ahnung ob das der
fall ist
ich hoffe es einfach mal macht die augen
zu scheiße
haug ist leider nicht so trotzdem kann
ich sagen es sieht eins zu eins aus wie
ein iphone
bis auf das hier aber das hat
wahrscheinlich auch rechtliche gründe
gut also können wir gerne mal den
kommentar schreiben was euer erster
eindruck dazu haben wir noch
logischerweise meine kopfhörer nummer
200 die herum fliegen wir haben ein
ladegerät natürlich nicht von apple
sondern android und wir haben sondern
adapter da kann ich eigentlich zweck mal
zu sagen diese adapter die ich über und
bestelle die sind extrem schlecht
wahrscheinlich wird der akku beschädigt
wenn man über so ein adapter sein iphone
lädt also ein originales iphone und die
lage generell viel viel langsamer also
keine ahnung woran es liegt aber die
sind nicht von guter qualität so das
war's der karton ist leer
ja wir haben wir das produkt wenn ich
mal gespannt
das geht sogar an eis ohne aufzuladen
also so sieht es aus das waren ziemlich
hoher ton so und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was passiert als nächstes
sollte handys hochgefahren wir machen
das jetzt einfach mal aus dieser
position stellen wir deutsch ein touch
gefällt mir direkt richtig gut also gar
nicht so verzogen starten jetzt via wlan
gesucht das ist unser ich richte das
jetzt einfach mal schnell ein und dann
melde ich mich wieder ist gleich so
leute willkommen zurück ich habe jetzt
alles eingerichtet das ist der
bildschirm den wir hier haben und ich
habe wirklich kommt dass auch hier die
ereignisse von den apps alle so aussehen
wie bei apple
jetzt halt nicht so das einzige was
gleich aussieht ist der hintergrund ist
halt auch der stimmen und hintergrund
vom iphone ist weil ich habe ich schon
ein paar videos gesehen wo das so war
das waren 1 android betrieben das
apple-gerät und da sah man halt auf den
ersten blick gar nicht also hier sieht
man ja direkt das ist ein fake ist und
da sah man es auf den ersten blick nicht
aber gut ich würde sagen wir vorher face
id testen schauen wir uns mal kurz
irgendwie ein youtube video an
mal gucken wie das ganze aussieht ich
muss sagen der touch und so ist gar
nicht mal schlecht also es okay also
dass auf jeden fall besser als gedacht
so was kann man schauen
also wenn man sich das bild jetzt mal
anguckt denke ich mir so what the [ __ ]
wieso ist denn da jetzt rechten rand
also irgendwas stimmt da nicht so ganz
mit an sich geht jetzt hier zwar flüssig
wenn dann irgendwas lädt dauert so ein
bisschen aber gut
hallo jetzt ist youtube abgestürzt
jannes ja wohl also so was wünscht man
sich doch direkt wenn man ein neues
handy bekommt das dann auch alles
tadellos direkt abstürzt genau genauso
wie haben wir das menü erinnert alles
sehr stark an ein typisches android
gerät kann ich noch ein handy meiner oma
schenken so trotzdem wurde ja mit face
aldi geworden und das schauen wir uns
jetzt mal an ob das wirklich gibt ich
mag es stark zu bezweifeln
aber man kann ja nie wissen dazu gehen
wir in die einstellungen display sperre
und hier haben wir jetzt muster pin
passwort also von face steht da nichts
eine ahnung ob ich jetzt einfach nur zu
blöd bin aber ich glaube nicht also
leute schaut euch das mal an was was
macht es hier
ich mache mal es wäre geht wirklich
nicht gut
also keine ahnung hätte ich mir für 100
euro auf jeden fall was besseres
vorgestellt vor allem ich habe jetzt
nicht mehr apps im hintergrund geöffnet
eine sache die wir auf jeden fall noch
machen können wir test man hier kurz die
kamera ach komm wir und die kamera ist
jetzt sogar so aufgebaut wie früher beim
iphone 4 mit diesem ding jetzt freue ich
mich gerade wofür hier die face kamera
ist wenn man die ja gar nicht benutzen
kann also wir sehen können ich kann
ihnen irgendwo die kamera switchen also
was sagt ihr zu kamera qualität
ich glaube auch das ist nicht der
absolute burner aber es ist okay ich
meine das hat 904 euro gekostet leute
was geht ab hier aus der iphone fake
perspektive dessen video ich euch jetzt
leider nicht zeigen kann weil das format
mit dem das handy videos aufnimmt nicht
mal meinen konvertierungs programm
kannte also keine ahnung ich muss sagen
die fotos sind ja gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich bin jetzt mal gespannt wie
dieses video hier ist ihr sitz direkt
schreibe es in die kommentare
kompletter müll oder noch ganz okay also
was sagt ihr zu kamera qualität
ich glaube auch das ist nicht der
absolute burner
aber es ist okay ich meine es hat 904
euro gekostet trotzdem muss ich sagen
dass ich 404 euro schon deutlich bessere
handys in der hand hatte und ich euch
niemals empfehlen würde das hier zu
kaufen aber ich kann jetzt wenigstens
für mich sagen dass ich mal eine leihe
von fake in der hand hatte das getestet
habe und was ich mit diesem handy jetzt
noch anstellen werde
seht ihr in den nächsten tagen weil ich
das ja gerne verkaufen möchte und ich
bin mal gespannt was personen wie in
deutschland bereit sind für einen fake
iphone xxl was auch immer auszugeben
also wenn ihr darauf gehabt und das
nicht verpassen wollte abonniert auf
jeden fall den kanal und dann kommt das
jetzt bald ich bin gespannt ansonsten
meistens mit dem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen gibt gerne doch nach oben
nochmal schnell zusammengefasst wir
haben hier ein android-smartphone was
vom design her aussieht wie ein iphone
wenn man ist dann allerdings startet
erinnert sehr sehr wenig an ein normales
iphone bis auf dieser startbildschirm
hier mit dem typischen iphone experten
mit diesen typischen farben die man ja
kennt ja also es hat mich überhaupt
nicht überzeugt dass die finger davon
ist auf keinen fall 100 euro wert also
leute
wir sehen uns ich wünsche einen schönen
tag und das war es von mir ich brauche
unbedingt einen neuen stuhl